the movie opens up with a former model
Gabby who accompanies a movie director
named Dan to his abandoned Riverside
house in a rural city of England due to
his busy schedule Dan has to return back
to London leaving Gabby behind with the
assurance that he will return in a few
days before departing though he answered
some movie scripts and asks her to read
them through suggesting she could be a
unique case of a model turning into an
actor despite her initial reluctance to
stay alone Dan somehow manages to
persuade her after he leaves Gabby
begins to unpack her belongings and
arrange them all in order during this
she hears a door Creek startling her for
a moment however she dismisses the sound
and proceeds to read the scripts a short
while later Gabby hears a knock on the
door so she goes to answer it it's a
delivery boy named JC who recognizes her
as a supermodel and expresses his
admiration unfortunately Gabby doesn't
show much interest in the conversation
and quickly shuts the door later she
looks at her aging face in the mirror
which makes her feel sad it appears that
she uses several skin care products to
retain glow in her face that night Gabby
has a dream in which she imagines
someone entering her bedroom and spying
on her a couple of days later Dan
returns and inquires about Gabby's
thoughts on the scripts she admits her
difficulty in understanding them and
instead expresses her desire to do a
modeling show with the renowned designer
named Max baligan than however
discourages her from returning to
modeling as she is already retired for
it and she can't work with a guy whose
name rhymes with his during their
conversation he also asks about Gabby's
experience in the house and she says
that she doesn't feel alone like she
thought she would she goes on to say
that she feels a strange Vibe and also a
sense of being watched as if the house
has a life of its own Dan is amused when
she talks about spirits and dismisses
the topic after this he heads off to
London Gabby walks back to the living
room where she stumbles upon a note
saying that Spirits don't use Joe Lang
aftershave believing that Dan wrote it
she hurries outside to stop him and
inquire why he left such a message in
response Stan assumes she's joking and
dismisses her concerns he says that he
didn't write the note Gabby cannot
believe that the spirits have such good
taste in aftershave following this Gabby
goes back into the house but her fear
intensifies upon discovering another
note that reads I am not your enemy in a
panicked State she rushes out of the
house and attempts to contact Dan but
her calls go unanswered left with no
alternative she summons JC and asks him
to inspect the house JC shows up and is
disappointed to find that it wasn't a
euphemism he conducts a thorough search
of the entire premises but finds nothing
amiss shortly after Dan also arrives but
he thinks she's playing some kind of
game this infuriates Gabby prompting her
to accuse Dan of confining her in the
house and having a secret accomplice
maker go insane in order to get rid of
her afterwards Dan calls his girlfriend
Nina and tells her that he will be
staying home for a night later in the
evening he takes Gabby to dinner to help
her divert her mind but ends up getting
drunk when they return home they Place
him chasing game around the house and
end up getting intimate with each other
after making out Gabby tells him that
she is aware of his relationship with
Nina Lamont the reason why he drives
back to London every night in response
Dan admits it but he claims that Nina
isn't a good lover like Gabby as their
conversation unfolds Gabby shares about
her first love Jimmy whom she met when
she was 15. according to her Jimmy had a
skin condition and wasn't that appealing
despite this she made love with him one
night and they spent the entire night on
the beach the following morning he
dropped her home on his moped but on the
way back he met with a brutal accident
that claimed his life that dude died
happy regardless of his death Gabby says
that she still feels his Spirit watching
over her around midnight Gabby wakes up
to find Dan has already left alone in
her bed she hears the door Creak and
Witnesses a chair moving on its own
moments later a man with a female wig
and painted nails suddenly appears in
front of her causing her to scream in
Terror in the morning Gabby awakens to
find Dan putting on his clothes sleeves
her to wonder whether the vision she
experienced earlier was a dream Dan asks
her to get ready if she wants to return
back to London but Gabby decides to stay
after he leaves Gabby makes her way down
to the basement where she discovers an
ancient typewriter and a wardrobe
sensing a presence of someone in the
house she attempts to communicate with
it using a handwritten notes posing
questions like can you see me are you
dead can I get the name of your wig
maker and do I know you in the next
scene we see Gabby putting on her makeup
and wearing a beautiful dress while
looking at herself in the mirror she
also talks to an unseen individual
addressing it as Jimmy and speaking
without fear in the midst of the Chit
Chat Gabby expresses that she has
fulfilled her aspirations since Jimmy's
passing now that her glory days have
passed and none of the scripts seem
suitable she believes it's time to
explore something new perhaps burning
things later that night Gabby watches an
interview with Max belligan on TV and
learns about his upcoming private event
where he plans to select a few lucky
people for his show excited she shares
this news with the invisible press
presence of Jimmy expressing her
intention to attend the event at
midnight Gabby is in her sleep when she
is woken up by the drunk JC and His
companion Mickey JC suggests that they
leave claiming that this isn't the right
thing to do but his friend insists that
Gabby is the key to helping him fulfill
his dream of becoming a fashion designer
a few moments later Gabby opens the door
and invites the two friends inside she
seductively sits on the couch and asks
JC to turn on some music Mickey
interprets this as a hint for intimacy
and begins to kiss her and touch her
body however she quickly pushes him away
saying not so fast Jimmy's gonna go get
the condoms Mickey then tells her about
JC's dream and asks Gabby to assist him
in connecting with the right people
however Gabby cautions JC to reconsider
his career path explaining that this
profession can take people to the top
but it can also abandon them in the
middle of nowhere following this
conversation Mickey asks JC to leave so
that he can have some private time with
Gabby innocently JC departs and Mickey
proceeds to force himself towards her
Gabby attempts to resist but Mickey
resorts to violence slapping her
forcefully and commanding her compliance
feeling helpless she breaks down in
tears and calls out Jimmy's name as soon
as she says so an invisible entity
intervenes pulling Mickey away from
Gabby and throwing him to the floor
confused Mickey throws some random
punches at the air but the invisible
force subdues him and pins him to a
table as a form of Retribution after a
brutal assault Mickey is eventually
allowed to escape yeah tell Goofy and
Donald what you saw the next morning
Gabby returns to the house after a walk
by the river she starts getting ready
for Max baligan's event and asks the
invisible Jimmy to accompany her as well
amidst this she lights a cigarette and
soon after the Unseen presence blows the
smoke back into her face after
witnessing this Gabby attempts to reach
out and touch the invisible Jimmy but
she fails she then questions Jimmy about
why he doesn't want her to touch him but
receives no response changing the
subject Gabby decides to serve Jimmy a
freshly brewed coffee she leaves the
coffee to brew and turns to retrieve two
cops as she turns back the invisible
entity unexpectedly splashes hot coffee
on to her causing a severe burn on half
of her face as a result Gabby collapses
to the floor in agony clutching her face
and crying out in pain in the next scene
we see Gabby who has bandaged her face
is peacefully asleep in her bedroom a
few moments later her phone begins to
ring stirring her awake the caller is
dead but Gabby chooses to ignore it
alongside the phone's ring she also
hears the distinct sound of typing
coming from the basement intrigued she
follows the sound but as soon as she
reaches the basement the typing noise
abruptly stops this time she proceeds
towards an old wardrobe and opens it
inside she finds a collection of dusty
coats and the same blonde wig that the
mysterious man wore in her earlier dream
in addition she comes across a yellow
box filled with numerous pictures of the
man from her dream these discoveries
sent shivers down her spine causing her
to drop everything to the floor just
then she notices a man in the mirror and
screams Gabby anxiously attempts to
Escape but the invisible figure seizes
her and pins her onto a table he then
proceeds to force himself against her
will later Dan becomes concerned when
Gabby doesn't answer any of his calls so
he decides to check on her upon arriving
he is shocked to see her brutally
battered State and inquires about how it
happened Gabby in a crying voice points
towards the pictures and informs him
that the man had been in the house the
entire time Dan heads to the basement to
investigate but finds no trace of the
man returning to Gabby he reveals that
the man in the pictures is Michael gigas
a once famous actor from 15 years ago
who often portrayed feminine roles Stan
explains that Michael's career took a
nosedive at one point which forced him
to sell all of his properties in order
to settle his deaths since then the man
disappeared Without a Trace after a
brief conversation Dan checks on Gabby's
burnt face and urges her to seek medical
attention at that very moment the
invisible Michael unexpectedly strikes
down on the head from behind knocking
him out Michael then covers Gabby's face
with his hand rendering her on conscious
after some time Gabby gradually regains
Consciousness and sees Michael visibly
Seated on a chair nearby he firstly
apologizes to her for breaking her trust
by impersonating Jimmy he then explains
that he has been invisible for so many
years that he's now uncertain whether
he's truly alive or merely an abstract
concept he goes on to share that his
life story resembles that of Gabby's
because he was also once a famous figure
like her but experienced a turning point
from which he faded Into Obscurity
furthermore he reveals a golden ring on
his finger which possesses the power to
render anyone invisible he admits to
having misused this ring for evil
purposes causing harm and Chaos in
people's lives however he eventually
felt guilty for his deeds and sought
refuge in this house where he began
writing scripts as a means to overcome
his guilt nevertheless his evil
Tendencies resurfaced when he saw Gabby
now Michael believes he can attain true
peace only by relinquishing his power as
a result he offers the ring to Gabby
urging her to use it as a blessing
unlike what he he did despite hearing
Michael's story Gabby remains convinced
that he is a figment of her dream and
will vanish when she awakens in order to
persuade her otherwise Michael asks her
to read his scripts it turns out that he
has written everything about Gabby ever
since she came to this house as Gabby
goes through it she learns that there is
no ending Michael explains that the
conclusion of the story including his
own faith is in her hands now with all
this in mind Gabby takes Dan's car and
drives away several days later Dan is
seen giving a house tour to Michael who
intends to buy his property back during
their interaction Dan notices a picture
of Gabby and wonders where she is gone
meanwhile Gabby is with her lover Jimmy
on the beach possibly due to a form of
time travel this time she asks Jimmy to
stay at her place to avert the tragic
accident the movie ends as the couple
rides away with Gabby wearing the super
powerful Golden Ring subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching